she said what's the psychology behind
your tagline the world's only white male
comedian I the psychology is I take the
most ridiculous and ironic statement and
I put it into one tag line and people
still don't get it they're just like
what about Louis CK you know what about
Dane Cook and i'll just be like he's
really he's really black or he's not
really male uh there's just people that
don't get it I just wanted to take the
most ironic ironic statement especially
in Hollywood and make it my tagline
should everyone have sort of their
personal brand mission statement you
know I most people can just say do good
work and be like my work speaks for
itself I don't I rather have a clever
tagline and trick people into thinking
uh triple thinking um I'm a really
really awesome comedian and now come see
my work so not everyone does it's great
for branding though is that what they
tell me do you have any tips on writing
about yourself in the third person you
know like for an IMDB bio is it awkward
uh well when I you know don't write your
own I am DB x 0 because it looks like
you're when you see one you could tell
oh you wrote and it's like by anonymous
or like some made-up name it's like no
listen you wrote it uh you've wrote it
about you know you're just kind of like
talking about yourself I mean even have
your mother right it would be a little
bit of a different point of view why yes
somebody may be made some people's
mothers in might be a good idea to write
it but yeah yeah people kind of write it
as if they're on their date like they're
on a date they're like I want to press
you on a first date here's my here's my
imd bio IMDb wat look watcher uh and you
know a lot of I mean a lot of bigger
celebrities don't really even have that
much of bio anyway so you can have a
towel right so in keeping with your
you're certain mission statement or your
personal branding do you find you have
to weave it into things or stay
consistent with that so that you're well
you know with you know doing uh you know
being the world's only white male
comedian um always I'm pretty much
always white and male the comedian part
is you know debatable but I'm always
that you're always gonna get that
whether it's funny or not or what the
content is so I'm kind of always
delivering
but I I've always kind of done an
exaggerated version myself I take kind
of real life things and then I'm like
what's funny about this and then that me
exaggerated somewhat slightly for video
so I kind of always deliver um you know
you know we are gonna get from me wait
for week so choose things about your
quote demographic or whatever that you
know probably won't change yeah I mean
you know dating is always gonna be
awkward uh work relationships work job
interviews are going to always be weird
and awkward and funny and I think anyone
who watches would be like oh yeah that I
I can relate somebody can relate to that
in some way and I think for me it makes
it easy to create and I think it makes
it easy for me to be genuine and easy
for me to connect
you